it's great to welcome Tom Hartman back
to the program today Thomas of course
host of the thom hartmann program and
author of the new book the hidden
history of the war on voting who stole
your vote and how to get it back tom
always great to have you on
thank you David it's always great to be
on your show so let's start with there
have been efforts to suppress the vote
for politically motivated reasons really
going all the way back to the beginning
when the electoral college was
established as the system that that
would determine who the president is I
think many in our audience know the last
10 or 15 years of voter suppression
tactics but what did it look like more
towards the beginning of the United
States electing presidents well it was
pretty sweeping I mean women were not
allowed to vote at all Abigail Adams
wrote a letter to John when he was at
the Constitutional Convention saying
don't forget the ladies and he sent back
a letter saying we will not surrender
our male prerogatives and she said then
we will foment a rebellion which didn't
go anywhere and and of course people of
color couldn't vote in several states
even white men who were not property
owners couldn't vote most of those laws
those were all state laws most of those
got blown up by you know by the Andrew
Jackson presidency it's a fascinating
story that probably longer you want to
get into but you know in the beginning
of the Republic and you had
conservatives like John Adams arguing
that men who didn't own property should
not be allowed to vote he was outvoted
in the Constitutional Convention so
there's not a property prohibition in
the Constitution but you know voter
suppression or rule by a an elite white
male majority as a long long history in
this country after the ratification of
the Fifteenth Amendment there were still
mechanisms to prevent black Americans
from voting although they they may be
unfamiliar to some in the audience can
you talk a little bit about how that
worked well you know the this is
post-civil war post you know the
amendment that said that basically you
may not prevent someone from voting
based on their on their previous
condition of servitude or their race we
went into what's referred to as the Jim
Crow era where black
people were forced to take literacy
tests you know recite the entire
Constitution or you know name all you
know 26 members of the South Carolina
House of Representatives or whatever and
and there were poll taxes I mean there
were all kinds of strategies that were
used to disenfranchise the black vote by
enlarge and some of those were also used
to disenfranchise the poor white vote as
well when we look today at the ways and
strategies and tactics that are used to
hold down turnout there's this
conventional wisdom that's often cited
that may or may not actually be that
wise about when turnout is lower it
tends to favor a more conservative
candidate if it's within a primary it
favors the more conservative candidate
within the primary if it's an election
between a Democrat and a Republican it
tends to favor the Democrat the the
Republican rather over the Democrat is
this true and historically did
suppressing the vote help the right more
than the left or was it an
equal-opportunity thing at different
points in history throughout history
suppressing the vote has helped the the
right more than the left because the
right represents the elite interests and
the simple fact of the matter is if
voting requires you to leave work for a
half a day and go someplace and do
something and jump through a bunch of
Hoops and particularly prove your
identity and things like that then
people who are wealthier who tend to
have salary jobs rather than hourly jobs
people who live in areas where there's
an abundance of access to to polling
places typically white suburbs find it
very easy to vote it's not all that
inconvenient whereas people who are
hourly workers find it far more
inconvenient far more expensive to vote
and so they tend not to as much on the
other hand you know the easy solution
that is what we've done in Oregon and
Washington State which is mail-in voting
and we've seen a substantial increase in
voter participation as a consequence of
that yeah of the of the sort of status
quo legacy elements of the voting system
that exists today so the electoral
college of course is one of them but
vote voting hours voting happening on a
Tuesday it not being a day that a lot of
people have off the limits on of voting
by mail and online voting which some
other countries have already put in
place is there one factor whose change
would most greatly enfranchise some
significant number of people yeah voter
suppression I mean this voter
suppression has become the go-to
strategy of the Republican Party
particularly since 2000 it's been
completely reinvented from the old
caging of the 60s or the intimidation in
the sixties when William Rehnquist stood
outside polling places in rural Arizona
Native American Hispanic polling places
and challenged voters and snarled at
people which is how he worked his way up
to being chief justice in the US Supreme
Court so he could and George Bush the
election in 2000 the it's gotten quite
sophisticated and there's this huge
thing called red shift where we see exit
polls which are the gold standard around
the world we overthrew a government in
Ukraine because there was a discrepancy
between the exit polls and the actual
government elect produced election
results I lived in Germany for a year
people in Germany vote on paper as they
do in all the European countries and it
takes two three four days to count the
vote but they issue the results
typically you know unless the elections
within a half-point tight they issue the
results the evening of you know right
after the polls close and they do it
based on exit polls the Carter Center
uses exit polls the UN uses exit polls
to determine when elections are fair and
honest and accurate and in 2000 the exit
polls showed that clearly that Al Gore
won Florida not just one floor of a
lunch Florida by tens of thousands of
votes but the actual vote count shifted
toward the red toward toward the
Republican Party and gave the election
to George W Bush this it turns out was
because Jeb Bush George's brother had
acquired a felon list from the state
where George was together from George
basically from Texas and compared that
felon list with the voter list in
Florida
now the felon list in in Texas was more
than half african-american and Hispanic
and African Americans and Hispanics
largely
representing a named pool that in the
case of african-americans is is Anglo
names they're the the people who own
slaves in this country or principally
Irish English and Scotch and Hispanics
all of their names have arrived from
Spanish or the vast majority of them so
when you compare a whereas on the other
hand Caucasians have names that come
from Scandinavian languages Baltic
languages you know Russian Czech in
Slovenian but there's there's literally
dozens and dozens and does it so there's
huge diversity in names so if you take a
Texas spelling list and compare it with
a Florida voter list what's going to
happen is you're gonna get a lot of
overlap in names between among
african-americans and Hispanics and Jeb
Bush was successful in throwing anywhere
from thirty to ninety thousand
african-americans and a lot of Hispanics
off the voting rolls in Florida in that
2000 election in 2002 with Tom before we
move on just to be clear so the audience
understands these are not people that
were felons in Texas who went and voted
in Florida these were merely people
sharing the name that's correct although
the assertion that Katherine Harris made
was that you know they were felons from
Texas who had moved to Florida in order
to vote so in 2002 with the help America
Vote Act the the Republicans wrote into
that act this thing called the
provisional ballot and Greg Palast calls
these placebo ballots which i think is a
great name for them if you show up to
vote and you've been purged from the
list like happened in Florida in 2000
with Jeb Bush if you show up to vote now
since 2002 and you're not on the voting
rolls they say well I don't see how the
voting rolls here but here's a ballot
anyway that's a provisional ballot but
you can vote on this and you vote you
think you vote and so well you know you
turn that in not knowing that
provisional ballots are only counted in
the case of an election being contested
in court that's it that's the only time
so your vote will not be counted and
even when it's contested in court if in
the three to five day window after the
election you didn't go to the Secretary
of State's office and prove who you were
and show your birth certificate and ID
and and and proof of identity and and
residency and proof that you were
registered to vote if you don't do that
your vote still won't be counted and
most people have no idea the provisional
ballots are never counted so they walk
out of the voting place and they say to
the exit pollster well I voted for
Hillary Clinton this time and the
pollster writes that down and this is
why by almost 5 percent margin the exit
polls in Florida Wisconsin Pennsylvania
and there was at least one other state
showed that Hillary Clinton beat Donald
Trump and yet the official tally showed
that Donald Trump beat Hillary Clinton
this red shift which happened in about
is that recall 15 or 16 states but it
was huge in those states this red shift
was purely originally back in the early
2000s you know I used to talk about this
that we all thought it was rigged voting
machines but it's not happening in blue
states it's only happening in states
controlled by Republican secretaries of
state and it's becoming quite obvious
now that what we're looking at is the
result of these massive voter purges
where you know again the exit polls
showed Stacey Abrams won Georgia
substantially and yet Brian Kemp is the
governor why because he was also the
Secretary of State and he threw hundreds
of thousands over a million over the
previous four or five years voters in
Georgia mostly people of color off the
rolls and now just in the last week Greg
Palast just finished this lawsuit on
Brian camp in Georgia provided his
Georgia voter lists to the governor of
Michigan back in the day you know when
it was Rick Snyder this a couple years
ago and bricks and but the Michigan
Secretary said Michigan is still
aggressively purging these these people
from the voting rolls I mean it's just
it's insane it's they're they're saying
oh yeah well they live in Georgia but
they come up to Michigan to vote and
it's double voting and so we've got to
get them off the rolls and we see this
in red state after red state after red
state and it is the reason the only
reason in my opinion why Republicans
control the Senate why they control the
White House why they have controlled the
White House since 2002 in in every
election the exit polls showed that John
Kerry and Ohio wiped out george w bush
just
they show that in 2000 you know Al Gore
won Florida the exit polls showed
Hillary Clinton beat Donald Trump this
and it's the only reason that they
control the Senate we see this in
multiple states the red states in
particular so this this is the big you
know this is the elephant in the room
this is the thing that we need to deal
with and we need to be waking people up
and educating them to this and it said
to the point where you know probably 95
percent of Americans don't know what a
what a provisional ballot means to the
point where if somebody hands you a
provisional ballot you freak out to the
point that you grab a bullhorn and start
yelling you know that you call the
newspapers I mean we need to start a
counter revolution to this very very
sneaky slick thing that these
Republicans have been doing since 2000
so this is kind of a good entry point to
the last thing I wanted to touch on in
the limited time we have left which is
whether Wisconsin goes to Hillary or
Trump becomes at least under 2016's
numbers irrelevant if we have a national
popular vote rather than the electoral
college so my question is how important
do you see that activism about trying to
get a national popular vote is it is it
a futile effort because we know that
outside of something like the national
popular vote interstate compact that
actually changing the way that elections
work at the constitutional level would
be very difficult particularly when the
Republican Party has won several
presidential elections because we go by
the electoral college rather than the
popular vote is that where our activism
should be or is it not a good use of
activism capital so to speak
in addition to fighting provisional
ballots or even eliminating the whole
concept and which is simply at Lots part
of the health more help America Vote Act
of 2002 and this gets fixed by the way
by HR 1 to a large extent but outside of
that yes and national popular vote.com
is where you can find all the
information on this compact and so far
you've got States representing a hundred
and seventy electoral votes who have
signed on to this it takes two what are
the two 80 270 270 thank you 270 to win
the win the presidency and so when you
get enough states to equal 270 electoral
votes
and basically you've wiped out the
electoral college and that's a whole lot
easier than doing it through the process
of constitutional amendment they've been
29,000 attempts to amend the
Constitution since the founding of a
republic and only twenty seven of them
succeeded but you know Virginia now is
back in democratic hands and it looks
like they're going to they're gonna join
this thing you know we still have you
know 110 electoral votes to get and
we've already got the big states like
you know California in New York our
Republicans are fighting this like crazy
in fact they're proposing legislation
the center right now
to say that your electors have to vote
the whole idea of faithless electors
gets blown out of the water the
electrons have to vote which is their
way of legislatively eliminating the
possibility of the National interstate
calm compact to do this
yeah preemptively trying to kneecap the
the entire effort the book is the hidden
history of the war on voting who stole
your vote and how to get it back we've
been speaking with the books author and
also host of the Thom Hartmann program
Tom Hartman Tom really appreciate your
time today thanks David it's great being
with you